I'm delighted to welcome you on this
very rainy night to what is inexplicably
sam Harris's very first lecture in New
York City which of course is where we
think he belongs I don't think that sam
harris needs any introduction to most of
this audience he's the author of the end
of faith religion terror in the future
of Reason a surprise bestseller and his
first book by the way that outspokenly
challenges one of the most
unchallengeable piety zuv american
culture that religion is such a great
force for good that it should be immune
from the rational criticism that we
apply to other major social institutions
before I turn the podium over to Sam I
want to tell you that our question and
answer period after his talk is going to
be conducted with written questions
there are little white cards in front in
the containers in front of your seats
and if you will be thinking about it and
writing down your questions during his
lecture volunteers will collect them and
I'll read them out so we can all hear
them and there won't be much of a delay
I will be reading as many questions as
possible after this period Sam will be
signing the books which are on sale in
paperback edition at the table over here
to the right in closing I have one final
thing to say to this audience as you
know the weather outside is quite
unpleasant so if a bolt of lightning
strikes this building or hits you on
your way out I suggest that you follow
the advice of the one and only Pat
Robertson and call on Charles Darwin for
help and and now without any further ado
Sam Harris
well thank you Susan and thank you all
for coming on this rainy night I also
want to thank the Center for inquiry and
the Society for ethical culture this
really seems like the the perfect
merging of two organizations to bring us
this talk I'm going to talk to you
tonight about belief specifically the
problem of religious belief our world
has been balkanized
into into separate moral communities we
have Christians against Muslims against
Jews that the majority of people in this
planet at the moment organized their
lives around a founding proposition that
that God wrote one of their books we
have many of these books on hand they
make genuinely incompatible claims about
the nature of this universe about the
disposition of certain real estate in
the Middle East we have the marriage of
quite literally first century or earlier
beliefs literally Iron Age philosophy
with 21st century destructive technology
this this on its face should be should
seem untenable to us so now I'm going to
say some very unpleasant things about
religious belief over the next hour and
I just want to warn you upfront that
that I know I'm going to offend some
people in this room let me assure you
that's not the point I'm not being
deliberately provocative
I am simply worried so I'm going to
worry out loud for the next hour or so
I'm mindful of the fact that that 90% of
our neighbors 90 percent of Americans
believe in a personal God 40 percent of
scientists believe in a personal God
literally a God who can hear our prayers
so I'm guaranteed to offend someone here
I know this as secular and audience as
I'm going to find but I just want to say
up front that I'm needless to say I'll
take your questions as Susan said
well what is it belief let's let's get
into this
for a minute beliefs are clearly
representations of the world but they
are more than that they are the
representations of the world that we
think actually represent the world this
is the distinction between a belief and
a hope say when you hope that something
is true you are representing the world
you are representing a possible state of
the world when you believe that
something is true you are actually
making your best effort to map reality
with your thoughts and this is why
beliefs pull the reins of our emotions
and our behavior so closely this is why
belief is really part of the the
cognitive the higher cognitive machinery
we have to generate expectations about
the world expectations about how our
behavior is going to change our
moment-to-moment experience this sounds
abstract to you just just imagine the
change that it would occur in you if the
fire marshal came in at this moment and
said this building is about to collapse
these are mere words this is a mere
sentence and yet should you give it
credence should you believe it to be
true it would it would completely
transform your physiology your neurology
or your your behavior rather quickly and
and so to with any other proposition
that has significant representational
content that believing a proposition to
be true is what opens us to the
representational content of any of any
what otherwise would be a string of
words so what do our neighbors believe
well 22% of Americans claim to be
certain literally certain that Jesus is
going to come down out of the clouds
sometime in the next 50 years
another 22% think he probably will
sometime in the next 50 years that's
that's 44% of the electorate now of
course this belief does not exist in
isolation
this it's not an accident that 44% of
Americans also believe that the creator
of the universe literally promised the
land of Israel to the Jews this is in
his capacity as an omniscient real
estate broker it and these beliefs are
knit together with with a myriad of
other beliefs infatuations with with the
end of history with apocalyptic prophecy
and these beliefs have have geopolitical
consequences this is not just what
people believe on Sundays it is actually
not an exaggeration to say that
something like half of us something like
44 percent of the American population if
they turned on their television sets and
saw that a mushroom cloud had replaced
New York City they would see a silver
lining in this cloud because it would be
a portent to them it would presage that
the best thing that is ever going to
happen is about to happen the return of
Christ or take another belief that we've
all been pummeled with this this debate
about intelligent design the idea that
the machinery of the living cell is so
complicated that it could not possibly
have been generated through naturalistic
processes this this is should be
genuinely troubling to us this really is
eroding the prestige of science in our
culture it is your children could well
be taught this pseudoscience in school
in biology class one of these days but
it's also important to recognize that
it's a bit of a red herring because 44%
actually in a in the last Gallup poll it
was up to 53% something like half of us
are creationists intelligent design is
not what they're fancy and they believe
that we were created from mud with
divine breath sometime in the last 6,000
years you know Adam and Eve and it's
nandi in a garden with a talking snake
and a hankering for apples but this is
literally the vision of the creation of
our species
or take another belief that really
should be this should just be a
curiosity to us until you see its
consequences in the world that the
Catholic idea that condom use is somehow
immoral this is this is a a genuinely
ludicrous idea I can assure you that the
the powers of the human brain are
insufficient to provide a good argument
for this but map this on to sub-saharan
Africa where literally millions
something like three and a half four
million people die each year from the
spread of AIDS and what you have there
are Catholic ministers literally
preaching the sinfulness of condom use
in villages were the only information
about condom use is the representation
of the ministry it seems to me that the
time for respecting beliefs of this sort
is long past this this is Jenna Seidel
stupidity it is really it is criminal
negligence of a sort that we would not
tolerate in any other institution yet
the Vatican cannot be criticized to the
degree that it should because it's the
Vatican and there's there is a
overarching taboo around criticizing
religious babe we have this we've all
assimilated this idea that we should
respect other people's religious beliefs
your neighbor has the right to believe
whatever he wants to about God and the
moral structure to this university is
the right to believe whatever he wants
to about what happens after death and
you should respect these beliefs merely
because he believes them where else in
our discourse do we play by these rules
what when was the last time anyone in
this room was admonished to respect
another person's beliefs about history
or geography or engineering or medicine
we we do not respect people's beliefs we
evaluate their reasons if my reasons or
good are good enough you will
helplessly believe what I believe that
is what it is to be a rational human
being reasons are contagious if I came
on this stage and said that the
Holocaust never happened you would be
under no burden whatsoever to respect my
beliefs we don't respect the beliefs of
people who think Elvis is still alive
and the people who make - all those
crazy pilgrimages to Graceland these
people do not get invited to sit on our
boards of directors they don't become
presidents of universities I mean that
that is that that is all well and good
except when you change the subject to
God and then all bets are off then the
sky's the limit you can be certain with
zero evidence and and respected for it
it is taboo to push that push the
conversation into criticism of your
beliefs so what I'm advocating really
and what I advocate in my book is a kind
of conversational intolerance I this we
don't need new laws we don't have laws
against Holocaust deniers you know that
you all we need is a a standard of
intellectual honesty where people who
pretend to be certain about things
they're clearly not certain about
receive some conversational pressure
with the this would all be accomplished
if we if we treated everyone who spoke
about God on the floor of the Senate as
though they had just spoke about
Poseidon let me just imagine imagine you
know we have all these hurricanes in the
Gulf and some senator gets it into his
head that we should really be praying to
Poseidon I mean this after all is his
jurisdiction this is
the ocean is reclaiming our cities it
clearly that would be the end of that
person's political career and yet it's
not like someone discovered in the third
century that the biblical God exists but
Poseidon doesn't with these claims have
exactly the same status so there is a
conflict between religion and science so
many of us many scientists have papered
over this conflict and no less a body
than the National Academy of Sciences
really the our most elite scientists has
announced that there is no conflict that
that religion and science ask different
questions and represent different ways
of knowing
well religion and science don't ask
different questions and they don't
represent different ways of knowing
every religion is making claims about
the way the world is if if Jesus does
come down out of the clouds like a
superhero
Christianity will stand revealed as a
science that will be the science of
Christianity every Christian will be
able to say told you so I mean here he
is look at his magic powers and a
sufficient display of magic powers it
would just take us a few minutes would
convince any scientist of the claims of
Christianity it take this this idea that
that religion and science are mutually
compatible and and ask different
questions and broadcast it on to the
current debate about stem-cell research
I missed it from a biological point of
view stem-cell research is one of the
most promising areas of research in
biology to generate medical therapies
for scores of conditions there are
literally tens of millions of people in
our own country suffering from diabetes
from spinal cord injury Parkinson's
full-body burns
and stem cell research is while who
knows when and how it'll pan out any
biologist will tell you this is what we
should be doing and yet we're not
funding it at the federal level the
concern from the religious point of view
is that we have to destroy three day old
human embryos to conduct this research
and the conference the ethical debate
stops there it is just merely asserted
from the religious point of view that
three-day-old human embryos have souls
you have souls in the petri dish you
have souls in the little girl with
diabetes you can't you know the interest
of who can weigh the interests of one
soul against another we never have to
get into the details because faith stops
the conversation you just have to
respect the faith proposition that life
starts at the moment of conception
whatever that means
well let's talk about the details for a
second perhaps it sounds scary to
destroy human embryos a three-day-old
human embryo is a collection of 150
cells they're arranged in a sphere there
is no brain there's no nervous system
maybe 150 cells sounds like a lot of
cells there are a hundred thousand cells
in the brain of a fly it flies have
brains they have neurons they have
neurons very much like our own if we
know anything at all about the
relationship between physical complexity
and the envy and the possibility of
having experience at the possibility of
having interests we know that more
suffering is visited upon this earth
every time we swat a fly than when we
kill a three-day-old human embryo it's
not enough to say they're potential
human beings given given the advances in
genetic engineering every cell in the
human body with a nucleus is a potential
human being given the right manipulation
every time the president scratches his
nose he's engaged in a holocaust of
potential human beings
it'd take the idea that there are souls
in these embryos well embryos at this
stage can split into twins so what
happens we have one soul that becomes
two souls embryos that even later stage
confuse into what's called a chimera
becoming a single individual so we have
we have two souls coming into one soul
that the arithmetic of souls doesn't
make sense no one is ever burdened with
the with the responsibility of trying to
make sense of it because faith stands in
for ethical argument so my argument to
you really and my argument in my book is
that either you have good reasons for
what you believe or you don't if you
have good reasons your your beliefs are
part of the general purview of
scientific rationality you know is that
we don't need to distinguish between
hard science and soft science of what
this includes history this includes all
into intellectual discourse where people
honestly represent the state of the
evidence and seek evidence and religion
is the only area of our lives where
having no reasons or having very tenuous
reasons is considered a boon really it's
considered it's often considered even
more ennobling to take this on faith
rather than the this is the the parable
of doubting Thomas so having noticed
this confrontation between religion and
science and faith and reason generally
many of us have become what is now
called religious moderates the religious
moderation really is the flavor of
religion that is that is acceptable to
so many people who are otherwise
rigorously honest in intellectual terms
and my book I in my book I criticize
religious moderation rather harshly and
this has actually been some of the most
controversial material in my book so I
just want to run through my argument
briefly about this because
it has raised some hackles the first
thing to say upfront is just that
religious moderation is better than
fundamentalism there's no doubt about
that religious moderates don't fly
planes into buildings religious
moderates don't organize their lives
around apocalyptic prophecy and that's a
very good thing but religious moderation
has some real problems the first is that
it gives cover to fundamentalism because
because religious moderates have made it
taboo to criticize faith they want faith
respected they want the whole project of
being religious being identified as a
Christian a Muslim a Jew to be respected
that it is impossible to call into
question that this basic project that
the the ethical tenability of raising a
child to believe he's a Christian as
opposed to anything else and under the
cover of this respect we are now
powerless to say the very harsh and
necessary things about religious
extremism that that we need to say is
because it is it is taboo you have to
respect faith a religious moderation
prevents us from even noticing the
differences among our religions it is
taboo to notice that all our religions
are not teaching the same thing they're
not all equally wise and where they do
teach the same thing they don't teach it
equally well where are the Tibetan
Buddhist suicide bombers if you think
for a moment that that the kind of
violence we see in the Muslim world is
borne of the Israeli occupation and our
misadventures in Iraq we should see
Tibetan Buddhist suicide bombers the
Tibetans have suffered an occupation
every bit as brutal and far more cynical
than any that we or the British or the
Israelis have imposed upon the Muslim
world something like a million 1.2
million Tibetans have died since the
Chinese occupation where are the throngs
of Tibetans in the street
it's calling for the deaths of Chinese
non-combatants where the Tibetans
blowing themselves up on Chinese buses
at weddings in crowds of children in
front of the offices of the Red Cross
and the UN it's not happening it's not
likely to happen it's not that you could
not possibly form a death cult out of
the principles of Tibetan Buddhism in
fact to some degree Zen Buddhism
informed the the worldview of the
kamikaze pilots during World War two but
you would have to work very hard to bend
the core principles of Buddhism into
this kind of orgy of violence you don't
have to work so hard as a Muslim and it
would be impossible as a Jane and the
Jane's that this religion of India that
has some 10 million subscribers I think
the core of their religion is
non-violence you no matter how deranged
you get by that your doctrine as a Jain
you will get less and less violent the
really religious Jane's cover their
mouths with cheesecloth so they don't
inhale a bug by no stretch of the
imagination can you argue that the core
principle of Islam is non-violence it is
taboo to notice this and it is
especially taboo among religious
moderates our own religious demagogues
will notice this we can have a Franklin
Graham will stand up and say Islam is an
evil religion they'll notice the
differences between religions everyone
else has the wrong religion but
religious moderates have met have
rendered this taboo I want to point out
that I'm not talking about a race or
ethnicity I'm talking about the
consequences of ideas I'm talking about
when I talk about Islam I'm talking
about John Walker Lindh the white guy
from Marin County who went off to fight
with the Taliban bit we are at war to
digress briefly into the our current
situation we are at war with Islamic
fundamentalist
not merely al-qaeda not extremist Islam
that the mainstream doctrine of Islam
contains this notion of martyrdom in
Jihad it contains this imperative to
convert subjugate or kill infidels
anyone who says it doesn't has not read
the Quran has not read the hadith or is
lying about them it is taboo to notice
this if you doubt this if you think I'm
sure there are people in this room who
are still thinking no no it youths can't
be religion this is lack of Economic
Opportunity it's lack of educational
opportunity opportunity in the in the
Muslim world just contemplate for a
moment the biographies of the 19 men who
woke up on September 11th 2001 and
decided to slit the throats of
stewardesses and fly planes into
buildings these guys were college
educated to a man many of them had PhDs
many of them had been educated in the
West they were middle class or better I
don't know how many architects and
engineers need to hit the wall at 400
miles an hour for us to get it into our
heads that this is not merely a problem
of education or economics these were not
guys who had spent a lot of time
agitating about regime change in the
Middle East these were guys who spent an
inordinate amount of time at their local
mosque in Hamburg talking about the
pleasures that await martyrs in paradise
and and demonizing infidel culture that
the circumstance we are in is much more
sinister than many want to realize it is
possible to be so well-educated that you
can build a nuclear bomb and to still
think you're going to get the 72 virgins
in paradise that is how partitioned the
human mind is and that is how how
balkanized our discourse is that is how
immune religious propositions are to to
critical pressure conversational
pressure in our discourse 40% of
scientists believe in a biblical God
that does not suggest that there are
good scientific reasons to believe in a
biblical god that suggests that 60% of
scientists are not doing their jobs that
there really is an argument to be won
here so the problem with religious
moderation another problem is that
moderates are blinded by their own
moderation a moderate doesn't know what
it's like to be certain of paradise a
moderate doesn't know what it's like to
be certain of God to be certain that the
book he keeps by his bedside is the
perfect word of the creator of the
universe and so when the moderate look
sees the jihadis in the video camera
saying things like we love death more
than the infidel loves life and then he
blows himself up
it's the moderate who's left wondering
well that couldn't be faith that is
propaganda that's I don't know what that
was but that's not religion so it is
really that the discourse of religious
moderation that keeps convincing us that
religion is not the problem that there
that this violence would happen anyway
these 19 guys would have would have
killed a lot of people anyway
there's no evidence for that another
problem with religious moderation is
that it is intellectually bankrupt it
really represents a fundamentally
unprincipled use of reason at least
fundamentalists talk about evidence the
fundamental you ask the fundamentalist
why do you believe that Jesus was the
son of God and the Bible is a perfect
Word of God
you'll get reasons that they're not good
reasons but you will get you will
immediately see that these people are
engaged in an evidentiary pursuit
they'll say things like the New
Testament confirms all of Old Testament
prophecy or every prophecy in the Bible
has has come true you know these are
specious claims but
contrast that to what moderates say
moderates don't talk about evidence
monitors talk about meaning they talk
about the good effects of believing as
they do now just take that kind of talk
into it into another area I would just
just changed God to some other consoling
proposition and appreciate what a non
sequitur that is as to the question why
do you believe in God it's actually an
example from my book
imagine your neighbor believes that he's
got a diamond buried in his backyard
that's the size of a refrigerator can
you ask him why and he says things like
what you understand that this diamond
gives my life a lot of meaning or you my
family loves the gatherings we have on
the lawn digging this pit every Sunday
and you are we going to take that away
from us or mentioned if he said I
wouldn't want to live in a universe if
where there wasn't a diamond buried in
my backyard that's the size of a
refrigerator it it's pretty clear it's
immediately clear that that those
responses would be inadequate deeply
inadequate those really are the
responses of a madman or an idiot and
yet take the same kind of thinking into
the religious domain and that these
responses have immense prestige in fact
unless you endorsed some thinking of
that kind you could not possibly get
elected to political office in this
country
another problem with religious
moderation is that it is theologically
bankrupt it it is not like if we just
read the books more closely we would
discover all these reasons to be
moderates but I Got News for you I've
read the books God is not a moderate
three what you find in these books you
there's no place in the books where God
says you know when you get to the new
world and you develop your three
branches of government and you have a
civil society you can just jettison all
the barbarism
I recommended in the first books if
these books really are engines of
fundamentalism they are engines of
intolerance there really is a wrathful
Jesus in the New Testament waiting to be
found in 2nd Thessalonians and in
Revelation where exactly the Jesus who
we have in the Left Behind series of
novels that 60 million people have
bought the Jesus of just fiery wrath
who's going to throw people into the pit
okay that is there to be discovered in
nowhere in the book does does it say
that's bogus
it's really it's not an accident that
people like st. Thomas Aquinas or st.
Augustine really the people who are
still taught as the great lights of the
Western tradition in a coins this case
he thought heretics should be killed
outright in Augustine's case he thought
they should be tortured Augustine's
argument for the use of torture laid the
foundations for the Inquisition this is
this is not an accident and it's
perfectly reasonable we have this idea
that that the fact that we were burning
heretics alive for five centuries in
Europe this represented some kind of
departure civilizational departure into
psychopathology it didn't it is
perfectly reasonable to do this if you
believe the books that the heretic next
door Givens certain beliefs it's far
more dangerous than the child molester
next door the the heretic can say
something to your child that will damned
his soul for all time
religious moderates lose touch with the
fact that it's possible to believe this
and finally the problem with religious
moderation is that it because it is
constitutive of merely our relaxing our
hold upon these ancient superstitions in
entebbe booze because it it doesn't call
the basic project of affiliating
yourself with these traditions into
question it doesn't doesn't call them to
question the project of venerating these
books to the exclusion of any other
books because it doesn't it prevents us
from developing modern 21st century
alternatives really bringing the full
measure of our creativity to bear on
questions of human happiness
now this is this link between religion
and morality that we really is
everywhere in our culture and which
which really under writes religious
moderation and religious fundamentalism
to a significant degree this idea that
without religion something fundamental
would be lost to us in moral terms this
really is questionable when you look at
the books the truth is that not even
just it to speak specifically the Bible
for a moment not even an Orthodox Jew or
a fundamentalist Christian can take God
at His Word
given how sadistic God is in in books
like Leviticus and Deuteronomy and
Exodus myth if you were going to draw
your to-do-list out of a book like
Leviticus you would make mullah omar of
the Taliban look like Franklin Delano
Roosevelt it's just it is it created
paints a vision of life so needlessly
horrible so subversive of the basic
project of creating a sustained a
sustainable society where human
happiness is even possible that we
effectively have edited the Bible even
fundamentalists have it but it it's
important to point out that nobody ever
says these passages are immoral and the
idea that you have to you find that a
woman is not a virgin on her wedding
night and you stone her to death you
stone homosexuals to death if your kids
talk back to you you stone them to death
if you go into a town and you see
someone praying to a foreign God you
kill him you kill his family you kill
everyone in the town ok these are not
metaphors these are not analogies for
some spiritual struggle within these are
explicit directives to kill people for
theological crimes no one ever says this
is immoral the Christians just say we
don't have to do this anymore because
Jesus brought us the doctrine of grace
well incidentally Jesus also said that
every jot and every tittle of the law
has to be fulfilled so the inquisitors
of the Middle Ages
had a rationale for practicing this kind
of law and I can assure you that st.
Augustine and st. Thomas Aquinas had had
read the Sermon on the Mount
they managed to square the Ministry of
Jesus with their impulses to kill people
for thought crimes if this is the best
book we have from the point of view of
fundamentalism this is the Bible's the
best book we have or the Quran is the
best book we have because it's literally
been dictated by the creator of the
universe from the from the point of view
of moderation these are the best books
we have but who knows what their sources
just that the smartest people who ever
lived wrote these books say if these if
the Bible is the best book we have in
the West in ethical terms we should be
practicing slavery the creator of the
universe clearly expects us to keep
slaves he seemed he simply tells us not
to beat our slave so severely that we
put out their eyes or their teeth Jesus
clearly expected us to keep slaves he
never criticizes the institution of
slavery he uses analogies with slaves
Paul in first Timothy admonished his
slaves to serve their master as well and
to serve their their Christian masters
especially well so that they can partake
in their holiness if this is the
abolitionists were absolutely on the
wrong side of a theological debate if
this is the wisest book we have the
slave holders of the south were right
and on so many other questions this is
true if this is the wisest book we have
we should be beating our children with
rods they say 'ya says in proverbs
incidentally fundamentalist Christians
in our country are beating their
children with rods
last year alone in Alabama forty
thousand kids were paddled in their
schools is legal to do this this is a
faith-based initiative
it's important for us to recognize that
we decide what is good in the good book
but we we cherry-pick these books based
on our own ethical intuitions all we
have to decide questions of ethics are
our own ethical intuitions and the
ethical intuitions of others who we are
in conversation with you can put your
faith in a 21st century conversation
about ethics or you can put your faith
in a first-century conversation as
preserved in these books and the problem
of faith really is that it is a
conversation stopper as long as you
don't have to give reasons for what you
believe you have effectively in the
immunized yourself against the power of
human conversation but you hear
religious people say things like there's
nothing you can say that will change my
mind
just imagine that said in medicine you
know if there's nothing that can be said
that will change your mind if there's no
evidence or argument that can be adduced
that proves that you are not taking any
state of the world into account in your
beliefs the problem with this is that
when the stakes are high we have a
choice between conversation and violence
at the level of society we have a choice
between conversation negotiation and war
the only a willingness to take on and
consider new evidence and new argument
guarantees that we this human
collaboration is open-ended only that
willingness guarantees that religion is
the one area of discourse where we have
made a fetish of a very different frame
of mind
and this this leads to two kinds of
violence two kinds of conflict refers
there is just first we can concede that
there's there are other sources of human
conflict there there would be wars
without religion there's tribalism
there's nationalism there there's racism
ethnic rivalry but there's no kind of us
them thinking that really makes a
transcendental object of the differences
between in-group and out-group I mean
the difference between you and your
neighbor is not merely skin color it's
not merely language it's not merely
politics it's not merely that you want
his belongings it's that this difference
in this means something for eternity and
so what you have are populations of
people who organize their their moral
identities around their religious
affiliation whether or not they care so
much about the theological details and
and this leads to conflict when a
society is stressed over and over again
we see society is breaking down long
along religious lines this happened in
Ireland Bosnia you know it's not that
the Irish were fighting over the the
doctrine of the transubstantiation but
their identities their core moral
identities were built around religious
affiliation then there's the other kind
of religious violence which is
explicitly theological where you
literally have people killing other
people because they think the creator of
the universe wants them to do it and
they think there will be a reward for
doing it and the preeminent example of
this is what we see every day on the
front page of the paper that this
jihadist violence
so my argument to you really an argument
in my book is that unless we call into
question this the dogma of faith unless
we call into question the idea that that
beliefs can be sanctified by something
other than evidence an argument we will
never successfully undercut the basis
for religious violence now I've said
many nasty things about religious faith
this this is not to say that religion is
merely a shell game this is not to say
that that all religion is just a tissue
of lies and misconceptions and cognitive
errors designed to anesthetize us
against our fear of death it is that to
some significant degree but it is more
than that that there is no doubt that
people have spiritual experiences I use
this word spiritual and mystical in my
book and and I use them in scare quotes
because frankly there are some many
there are many embarrassing associations
with these terms but there is no doubt
that people have extraordinary
transformative experiences and can have
them deliberately connected that every
culture has produced people who have
gone off into caves for 40 days or 40
years and discovered that a deliberate
use of attention of introspection
through meditation through prayer this
can really transform the human mind and
the testimony we have on this subject
comes to us through our religious
traditions and unfortunately therefore
it is mingled with all manner of
superstition and dogma and is not it's
not mingled to the same degree in every
tradition and this is this is also taboo
to notice that our contemplative
traditions our spiritual traditions are
not equally insightful
east and west for instance it's a bit of
a a cultural mystery as to why this is
so but the eastern tradition has been
the Indian tradition generally in
Buddhism especially has been so much
more sophisticated so much more
empirical in their study of first-person
experience just in their study of what
it is possible for a human being to
realize if he or she just pays close
attention to the flow of experience
there are analogs in the Western
tradition there are there have been
great Christian and Jewish and Muslim
contemplatives yes I mean that in the
context of every ideology there are
people making the best of it
but the difference east and west in turn
in contempo of terms really is like the
difference between Western medicine and
Eastern medicine if you have an
appendicitis you better hope that you're
near a Western hospital with a Western
trained surgeon you don't want to see
your acupuncturist maybe there are some
things that are that Eastern medicine is
better for but generally speaking
Western medicine is is the only medicine
we have and incidentally if you do get
an appendicitis you might consider this
idea that you've been intelligently
designed if ever there were a reductio
ad absurdum of idea of intelligent
design it's the appendix so in the West
we really have we've had an impoverished
conception of sanity really we've had an
impoverished conception of mental health
what we think that you know if you're
walking down the street talking to
yourself too much and we all do it a
little but if you're doing it too much
and not censoring yourself in front of
other people you're crazy but if you
talk to yourself all day long silently
if you just know enough to shut up about
it but you're talking to yourself
thinking thinking thinking from the
moment you get
to bed - the moment you fall asleep
that's perfectly normal
that's compatible with perfect sanity
that is not the eastern and especially
it is not the Buddhist view me in
Eastern schools of meditation they have
discovered that there is an alternative
to being lost in thought moment by
moment in the West the testimony on this
subject is really thin I mean we in the
West we have been standing on the
shoulders of dwarves in contemplative
terms so I just want to briefly sketch
for you what I think are contemplative
traditions attest to and this is
something that is actually getting a lot
of scientific interest at this point as
you probably know there are meetings
between the Dalai Lama and Western
neuroscientists I just came from one in
in DC and this was this was devoted
specifically to the clinical
applications of meditation but there's
there's dialogue between Western
scientists generally and and
contemplatives about how first-person
data first-person experience can be
brought into the the Charmed Circle of
third person experiment and how we can
use this to to understand the
possibilities of human well-being a
little bit better
so briefly the the the first fruit of
this dialogue really is the insight that
positive human emotions
positive human traits Archer are skills
they are trainable but just as you can
learn to play the piano you can learn to
feel compassion for somebody when you
otherwise wouldn't you can learn to feel
joy at the success of another person
rather than envy and you and you can
learn this because our brains are really
plastic our brains are our instruments
that change based on how they are played
it's really quite magical that this is
so but it it it certainly seems to be so
who knows to what degree our experience
can change the brain and therefore
change the possibilities of future
experience but we know that it does and
therefore what you think matters what
you what you feel matters how you the
kinds of intentions you form toward
other people matters whether you act
ethically matters and and what you pay
attention to moment to moment what you
notice matters and even just matters for
health we know that stress is so
corrosive of physical health now we know
that even if meditation did nothing
other than reduce stress it would be
worth looking into we know that the
brain is is intimately linked with it
obviously the autonomic nervous system
but the endocrine system the immune
system these systems are affected by by
your conscious emotional life and in
turn affect the brain its physical
structure but there's a deeper message
from our contemplative traditions beyond
that we can change our minds the the
message is there's something beyond the
the search for pleasure and pain there's
something beyond joy and sorrow and just
the vicissitudes of human experience and
that in what is beyond is not some
distant paradise it is simply
consciousness itself there is this
insight that consciousness that very
thing that is aware of your experience
in this moment the very the very thing
that is hearing the sound of my voice
that is feeling the the sensation of
your body sitting there that transcends
its content in some basic sense that
that which is aware of joy for instance
and that which is aware of sorrow
is not actually improved by joy or
diminished
by sorrow and what meditation is is a
way of just turning consciousness upon
itself to try to glimpse this fact and
and to glimpse the way it feels
because one of the it doesn't feel like
a self it doesn't feel like I we all
walk around feeling like we are the
thinker of our thoughts and the
experiencer of our experience we feel
like we are having experience we're not
merely identical to our experience and
this this point of view is really
vulnerable to inquiry I mean if this
seems just impossibly abstract but by
analogy I just want to point out to you
maybe I can tie it tie it down to
something that that we all know is so we
all know we have an optic blind spot we
all know that the optic nerve passes
through the retina and so there's a
point in our visual fields where we're
not getting any information we've all
probably had this demonstration done in
class where you do a mark on a on a
piece of paper and you you play with it
and you get the mark to disappear now so
it is it is true of you now there's you
know as you look out across the room
there's somebody very likely missing a
head and you're not know it's falling in
your blind spot it is possible to be
made to notice this most people don't
notice that even those of us who know
about it go for decades without noticing
it and yet it is it is there available
to be noticed there is an analogous
insight into the nature of consciousness
that is just as on the surface as that
it tends to be harder to notice it
requires most people some training and
meditation to notice it but it is
possible to notice that consciousness
what that in you which is aware of your
experience does not feel like I and this
this there's a wealth of testimony on
how this can
a person's experience of the world for
the better there's a kind of mystical
well-being that is compatible with going
into a cave for a year we going into a
cave for most of us going into a cave
for a year is synonymous with everything
we don't want to happen to us it
separates us from everything we want out
of life
it's rather interesting to point out
that solitary confinement is considered
a punishment even in a prison and yet
you have contemplatives who are willing
and and made really quite happy by the
by running this experiment on themselves
going into a cave for vast amounts of
time and practicing meditation my
argument to you is we have to bring this
end of the human extend of the spectrum
of human experience into the data of our
worldview we have to understand the
possibilities of the plasticity of human
experience and our conception of human
well-being has to include this so in
conclusion I want to say that we really
need is a contemplative science we need
a way of talking about human well-being
and the possibilities of human happiness
that is as totally unconstrained by
dogma as Sciences we need we need to
find a way of talking about the reality
of death
the fact that we are all going to die is
an astonishing situation if you can just
hold on long enough your that you are
going to witness the death of everyone
you love and and this is everyone's
experience no one is going to escape
this if if this if it is possible to be
happy in this condition it if it is
possible to be deeply happy in this
condition we need to understand this in
terms that
don't rely on divisive superstitions the
if there is if there's an important role
for ritual in our lives if we need to
mark those occasions in every human life
birth and weddings and and deaths with
profundity if this is actually doing
some serious work for us we need to
understand this in in rational terms we
need to develop language that is not
first century superstition so my one way
to summarize what I've said to you is
that I'm really arguing that every one
of us is a scientist in that every one
of us is making a claim about the way
the world is every one of us wants to
understand reality none of us want to be
confused none of us want to be mistaken
about the situation we're in but there
there are areas of intellectual honesty
in our culture where science is is good
and there are areas where we have a
fundamental double standard where
certainty has been unlinked from
evidence but just as everyone as a
scientist everyone is also a mystic in
the sense that everyone every one of us
has been born into a circumstance where
we are helplessly seeking happiness in a
condition where experience is always
changing what you get you lose and we
are all interested whether we have time
to think about it or not we are all
interested in finding just how happy how
much well-being can be enjoyed in this
circumstance and in designing a
civilization that can promote it so I'm
just asking you to imagine what it would
be like to have a society where our
conversation about human well-being
could proceed totally unconstrained by
Dogma we're really we could bring the
full measure of our creativity to bear
on questions of human happiness and my
argument is that to get there to get
from here to there the end game for
civilization is not mere tolerance of
other people's irrationality it is not
political correctness it is reason thank
you very much
thank you
right as your questions are being
collected they're going to be brought to
me and meanwhile while they're being
brought I will start off Sam with a few
questions one of the questions I'm asked
most frequently in interviews is and
I've been asked it many times what's to
prevent you from going out and
committing murder if you don't believe
in God what do you say to people who
insist that there can never be any
morality without religion well yeah as
you say this is an incredibly common
question and we're all wise to prepare
an answer for it I've happened to have
one I mean what one counterpoint to this
this suspicion is we just just look at
at the societies where there is the
least homicide the least violent crime
these really are the most atheistic
societies on the planet if you just look
at the the UN Development Index that
which ranks societies by violent crime
by literacy by by educational attainment
by per capita income without exception
apart from the presence of the United
States somewhere in the top 20 these are
the most atheistic societies on the
planet societies like the Netherlands
and and Canada and Australia Sweden
there is no evidence whatsoever that
high levels of religious adherence leads
to a moral society in fact if you look
at within our own culture if you look at
you know the red state blue state
divided we're where most of the murders
occurring where most of the the teen
pregnancies even and even the abortions
these are happening you know in in those
states that have the highest level of
religious adherence okay here come your
questions I'll ask you one more while I
vet these
I'd like to I'd like you to pick up on
some of the things you said about
Eastern religion because it seems to me
that in a way you give Eastern religions
kind of a pass on the whole issue of
rationality for example a Dalai Lama
just had a piece in the New York Times
which I'm sure everyone here read and
there didn't seem to me to be much
difference between his views on the
relationship between religion and
science and that of the moderate Western
religions you criticize would you
comment on that yeah well one promise
that we have this one word religion and
as though this named a really a
homogeneous class of infatuations and
and doctrines and it doesn't the
religion is a word like drug I mean
their drugs you have aspirin and you
have heroin and that and they're not
very similar in terms of their effects
on a human life and while there are many
wacky and unsupportable dogmas within
every religion within Buddhism they are
they're different and there's a there's
a spirit of empirical rigor that the
Dalai Lama has for instance he's gone on
record over and over again saying if
science demonstrates something that some
doctrine of Buddhism is false then
science wins he has that to some degree
that's a blank check because some of the
some of the most some of the doctrines
to which most Buddhists are attached our
doctrines and science is not likely to
weigh in on anytime soon but there is a
difference and I'm you know while I
criticize Buddhism in a very long
EndNote in my book it's it is distinct
from from Islam and as Islam is distinct
from from almost every other religion at
this moment here is a great question
from the audience while we as adults
agree with you totally how do we begin
to reach our young children or
grandchildren how do we teach our young
children our grandchildren about life in
this respect when those under the age of
seven the age of reason
not understand these ideas in the midst
of this society but I think kids unless
they're conditioned otherwise don't come
into this world believing themselves to
be Christians or Muslims or Jews but we
give them these ideas they don't just
pluck them out of the ether and so it
seems to me that simply giving honest
answers to their questions and certainly
lifting this this this tableau of saying
I don't know we're so reluctant to say I
don't know and incidentally scientists
are the people who are really good at
saying I don't know they say I don't
know all the time because they're
terrified that some specialist is going
to be in the room who knows so much more
about what they've been asked that you
know you can almost never get a
scientist to weigh in on anything but
his most narrow area of specialization
and this is slightly off topic but
notice the fact that scientists that
science is paying a price for this in
that fundamentalists are really good at
using the the the candor of science
against it me that whenever scientists
say I don't know on Larry King Live
they're in rush
thousand fundamentalists beautiful
giving us the God of the gaps there and
that's really really what intelligent
design is it is it is politics and
religion masquerading as science do you
think the right wing actually believes
in religion or does it simply use
religion to mobilize the masses to
support the fight for finite natural
resources like oil well that that is
spoken like a true religious moderate
yeah incidentally I needles to say I
believe that people many people most
people most of the time really believe
what they say they believe and they're
there their allocations of time and
energy attest to this certainly a
willingness to blow yourself up attest
to this but the people who are standing
out on the sidewalks with the placards
protesting homosexuality
I believe they really think
homosexuality has been prescribed by God
and and incidentally that is why the
First Amendment to the Constitution is
is not good enough to keep religion out
of politics it is only rational to be
motivated by what you think is true if
you really think there is a God who
hates homosexuals it would be totally
irrational to live in a society that
just happily live in a society that just
tolerates homosexuality so I actually do
believe people believe these rather
unbelievable things what percentage of
your reader feedback has been hostile
and how hostile but that's actually been
a pleasant surprise I would say at this
point something like 99% is is really
quite positive and quite quite
supportive and then there the the crazy
emails but nothing nothing terribly
scary either so that's been good what in
your mind is the proper relationship
between atheism and libertarianism
actually it's an interesting question
I've never thought about that but
there's there is a there's a link in the
sense that really that the core idea of
libertarianism is that peaceful honest
people have the right to be left alone
and this is this is trespassed rather
obviously by the religious right in
their in their impulse to to legislate
what goes on in the bedroom and in other
aspects of our privacy so libertarians
are very much well they are conservative
in
and in ways that that don't satisfy many
liberals they are they're fundamentally
against this idea that that you can
intrude upon your neighbors pursuit of
happiness because you don't like his
behavior his behavior doesn't affect you
if it doesn't affect your property and
then consenting adults should be able to
do whatever they want and it seems to be
a seems to me a very sensible way of
looking at it
if neuroscience ultimately shows if it
hasn't already the religious zealot tree
has a chemical or genetic component then
what solutions do you have to the whole
question of world or religious peace
asterisk note that half of all
scientists are religious may be the
direct measure of this genetic component
yeah well it all has a genetic and
chemical component every aspect of our
experience then the nature nurture
divide has been somewhat oversold again
I would point to Western Europe there is
a level of unbelief in Western Europe in
a country like Sweden for instance that
is just the polar opposite of our
situation here we have something like
three or five percent of Americans who
will call themselves atheists and maybe
ten percent who are who are just
fundamentally unsure we have we have
ninety percent basically eighty three
percent of Americans believe that Jesus
literally rose from the dead something
like eighty percent depending on how the
question is asked eight sixty to eighty
percent of Swedes are atheists so unless
you're going to allege some real genetic
difference between swedes and Americans
it doesn't seem like a genetic problem
it really to my mind is a conversational
problem this is related why is the
United States going backward in terms of
its attachment to religion while the
rest of the educated world Westar
Europe and Asia is going forward in
other words what accounts for the the
extraordinary persistence of
fundamentalism in America compared to
the rest of the developed world
yeah well it's a it is a persistence I
don't think it's I don't think it's that
we're necessarily going backwards it's
certainly become more visible and has
become politically more empowered but
the levels of fundamentalism if you look
at just the Gallup polls over the last
70 some-odd years that that the numbers
of people who believe that that Satan
literally exists for instance have been
really constant within a few percentage
points me incidentally it's 68 percent
of Americans believe the Satan literally
exists and twenty-eight percent believe
twenty-eight percent believe that
evolution is a scientific theory backed
up by evidence I mean the most tenuous
possible accommodation to the last 50
years of molecular biology in the last
hundred years 150 years of biology so
the arguments against religion what
specific practical practices can replace
the portions of religious ritual that
deal with human fears and anxiety about
death for example okay it's a good
question for which I I don't have a any
kind of comprehensive answer I mean
something that I'm thinking about it's
something that we have to make up out of
our own honest conversation it is it is
it is it's really not the kind of thing
that can be engineered in advance I mean
people just have to start being honest
with one another and see where that
honesty takes them when you're not sure
of something don't pretend to be sure oh
and and and these nuances are are
preserved even even fundamentalists are
intellectually honest generally I mean
that no one is no one is eager to go by
the Brooklyn Bridge as a fundamentalism
they want evidence
they want they want an honest
representation of the state of the world
it's just that we have dumbed down our
conversation so much on on the the
territory of religion that we are
playing by a different standard and so I
think it's it's for us to find out what
would take the place of superstition and
taboo what do you think of Anne Rice's
new novel about Jesus I I haven't read
it I'm I think I'm unlikely to read it
she's going to sell a lot of books
without me so I don't know some of you
may have seen The Colbert Report about
that said Anne Rice has gone from
writing about guys who want to drink
your blood to writing about a guy who
wants you to drink his blood not mine I
wish I'd thought about that how do you
restart a conversation with someone who
says nothing you can say will change my
mind well it's hard you know I've been
on AM radio enough to know that there
are people who you can't talk to it's
it's really there are people there are
doctrines that are hermetically sealed
where the the the person like me who's
going to challenge the belief has been
demonized in advance as a temptation I
mean the moment you start to sound
reasonable enough so as to shake
someone's faith you are suspected of
being the Antichrist me or you this is
the day they are prepared for a
sufficiently alluring counterpoint to
their their dogma so it's and in the
Muslim world this is also I think it's a
deeper problem actually because the the
the taboos around criticizing faith are
literally enforced by capital punishment
in so many Muslim countries I mean UK it
is you take your life in your hands
making the noise as I'm making in any
Muslim community on this
and it's not not just in the Middle East
I'm talking you know we're talking in a
suburb of New York it is not this kind
of conversation is not being had in the
Muslim world and it's we have to find
some way to inspire it but it's how we
how we do that is is a genuine problem
science specifically quantum mechanics
has shown mathematically that we live in
one of an infinite number of possible
universes why is this acceptable while a
belief in God is described by you as
superstition you know that's an
interesting question I think it was
Martin Rees the the Royal astronomer of
Britain has said that inflationary
physics this idea that we could live in
one of innumerable number universes all
functioning by different laws suggests
that there are probably infinite numbers
functionally infinite numbers of
technologically advanced civilizations
existing right now and and and these
technically advanced civilizations would
have almost by definition invented
computation and invented computers and
they'd be able to simulate universes on
their computers and it stands to reason
there would be more of these simulated
universes than actual universes and
therefore on this reasoning we should
suspect to be in a simulation rather
than in a real universe now I guess the
only thing I want to say about that not
being a physicist is that physics
appears to have achieved such a state of
verification that it's it's almost
impossible to know when a physicist is
joking
so I you know nobody nobody's going to
be burnt at the stake or stoned to death
or imprisoned for a difference of
opinion on cosmology and I think it's it
it's for physicists to decide what is a
rational claim to to knowledge in the
just the discourse of physics if you
ever believed in a god what happened to
make you begin to question that belief I
didn't I didn't believe in that kind of
God I believed okay we've all believed
many things that now embarrass us in
hindsight but no I never was quite that
far afield do you see any downside to
excessive meditation which could result
in being disassociated or spaced out we
are can exemplify that being
disassociated spaced out right now yeah
you know this is it's like anything else
it's it we are imperfect people devoting
ourselves to various pursuits and you
know every every Buddhist community
every meditative discipline has its
casualties and has and can select for
people who are not all that good at
gratifying their desires in the world so
you have a lot of you know the people
who go into a cave for a year you know
not all of them are the next Buddha some
of them are very likely quite neurotic
and not not happy in their lives so it's
a you just have to be you have to
separate the the various variables but
it is quite possible to I would imagine
meditate in a way that isn't good for
you good for you based on who you happen
to be or
good for you because you're either doing
it wrong or it's the practice is not
suited to you in the way that it's
possible to exercise in a way that's not
good for you you know there's nothing
wrong with with jogging except if you
have bad knees except if you have a bad
back except except so they're there it's
almost certainly an analogous issue with
meditation do you think that
fundamentalist Christians in the United
States would really have any objection
to fundamentalist Islamic theocracies if
they didn't support terrorism oh yeah
they would have an objection it's just
it wouldn't be so troublesome a it's the
wrong religion you know from from the
point of view of Christianity all those
people are going to hell and the Muslims
have returned the favor all the
Christians are going to hell so this is
pretty broad but I'll read it out do you
think that modern secularism is an
evolutionary transition to another state
of consciousness or is it the end of
evolution yeah I'm actually not a fan
and I've received some heat for this I'm
not a fan of words like secularism and
atheism I don't think we have to name
that the counterpoint to religious
irrationality we don't have words to
this to describe not being an astrologer
or not being an alchemist I mean nobody
wakes up in the morning says I'm not an
astrologer I'm not an astrologer
and and just to some degree I think the
same will work for not being duped by
the false certainties of religion it's
we simply need to apply reason we can
talk about being rational I don't think
we have ultimately I don't think we have
to talk about being secular so Sam why
do you uppercase G and God in your book
I know the answer but well it's just
it's the I guess I could play the the
copy editor did it but it's just the
it's the God most people believe in and
most of most of the readers are not
believing in one God amid many other
gods they think exists there's there's
the one God the biblical God which is
the Quranic God I think we'll close with
this question seems to me very important
what practical steps can we take as
individuals in our individual lives to
bring about the conversational
intolerance you advocate well it's
interesting so I'm not I'm not actually
recommending that we just oppose every
claim to religious conviction wherever
we find it I'm not I'm not recommending
that you know in a closed elevator you
hear someone talk about Jesus and you
you unleash on them it's really it's
really just in situations like this but
as a start I think well you know when
you're at the podium or when you're
writing an editorial for an opinion
piece for the newspaper or you're in
you're in a situation where you are
advancing the conversation about ideas
it seems to me that we all have a moral
responsibility to be deeply honest about
these things and you know so I'm not
advocating that we all rush back and
destroy every Thanksgiving dinner over
over these issues but
and then who knows where it would go
from there I mean there's there's a
there is a there's room certainly for
being civil